what's your formula or process for
telling a good story you know this is a
really great question I think that
storytelling you know I am NOT a verbal
person I am a visual person and you
constantly if you're Steven Spielberg
self-edit before you even go out on a
stage you know go on the location you
already know what you want being Bing
Bing Bing if you're really fortunate I
think and I always used to say this when
I was doing commercials you know Ridley
Scott builds 180-foot wide-set and when
the when the scenes over with you look
at and they only use 12 feet of it you
know he's got that luxury in independent
filmmaking you don't have that luxury
and in and quite frankly you have to be
intuitive enough to recognize what your
your quest is and in storytelling you
know it is is that seem really necessary
where the little girl goes and knocks on
the door and says you know hey you want
to come out and play can we just cut to
her you know already there and and then
you start self editing and typically
this is motivated by your desire to keep
the story intact but be inventive and we
had to do that all the time you know and
and I think specially having even though
Jen wrote the script Jo Gamache who is
one of the producers is also a writer
and he was able to on the fly help us
simplify scenes you know that were
sometimes over complicated and I'm not
talking about the writing I'm talking
about having to shoot it from six angles
and it's interesting because when you
read or hear interviews like you're
doing on me from great filmmakers
typically especially someone like Clint
Eastwood will actually talk about the
fact that why'd that scene only
from one point of view and he goes
that's all I needed and and even the
actors complained they wanted don't I
get a close-up you know and and I
thought to myself it's it's it's it's
Clint Eastwood's got a lot of balls you
know to be able to wake up in the
morning and just say no you know and
it's it's so funny because I'm always
fascinated about reading about back
stories about other filmmakers and you
know it takes a lot of guts and a lot of
self confident to take the most dramatic
scene in your movie my last film girl on
the edge there's a very climatic
dramatic moment where Peter Coyote is
talking to Taylor sprite ler the star of
the film and it's a very serious moment
and we just organically felt this isn't
going to be covered in and we all
handheld and we'll do it from a couple
moves on the fly but we will not do new
setups we'll just keep filming and that
works for me you know and it worked for
the film because from an editorial
standpoint you're not putting together
five angles emotions that are drifting
you know one moment you might feel it's
great to talk about this and get close
and the next take you might not and and
that's I think actors appreciate that
giving them the freedom to bring out
storytelling in a way that is more
coming from their hearts
you